good citizens of the reject Nation I
just got out of black panther wakanda
forever and I am a bit uh overwhelmed
admittedly I'm gonna go all my positives
first and then I've only got a couple
qualms I'm gonna save that for the end
all this is non-spoiler by the way this
is a movie that is a mix of a barrage of
Sight and Sound and stimuli mixed with
moments of pure poignant sadness it is
so sorrowful it is so
intentionally
remorseful and and thoughtful that it's
not quite like anything else in the MCU
and all of phase four has been very
intentionally about rebirth and death
and the experience of mourning and what
it means to be alive and what it means
to not and they had the thankless task
of not only following up one of the
greatest comic book films of all time
one of the most unique comic book films
of all time but they then had to do it
without Chad Boseman in a phase about
loss needed to address the loss of the
Black Panther and I think that
not only did they handle that
masterfully
but it was able to illustrate so much
more and
it's one of those you know diamonds come
from pressure situations where there's
so much Beauty in the sorrow of this
story and the pressure they were under
the agony it must have been to make this
movie translated into some really
spectacular art they have introductions
to uh ironheart one of my favorites
newer Marvel characters they have
introductions to namel one of my
all-time most he's not one of my
favorites that's not fair to say but
he's a character I always look forward
to seeing how he's dealt with he's a
character that's hard to write he's a
character that isn't easy to navigate so
when he's great I'm thrilled because
it's a character I want to be great so
they have a character that's very
divisive by his nature in the story
that's handled pretty magnificently they
have uh a a nation that is uh in
mourning that is also dealing with the
ramifications of how black panther ends
and they juggle all of that while
telling a very important story that
deals with
says this is a movie I'm more excited to
talk spoilers about than most because
the the things that juggles and things
it deals with I I didn't know going into
it I got off social media the weeks
leading up to this to make sure I didn't
know anything but most of all I love
that as a comic book fan there were a
lot of really really impactful images
that I didn't see in any marketing
whatsoever there's a lot of imagery that
comes straight from the comic books that
ties more directly into the the
iconography of black panther than I
think even the first one did so there's
a lot of things that I really was
impressed by as a comic fan to to get
the movie itself has
a ton of action set pieces but what I
loved most was
the the fast and furious with all the
family I got to
experience
Humanity through super human
circumstances the thing I love about
these movies is you know they're often
moral and ethical stories told through
the Trojan Horse of a blockbuster this
one leans way more drama than
Blockbuster this one leans way more
introspective than explosion and when it
does go explosion it does it very well I
don't think there's anything quite to
compare it to except for that it might
have more DNA with
eternals than say Iron Man but I think
that's its strength um I think it does
what eternals did whilst moving at a
more feverish Pace I think that when it
stops to really breathe it kind of is
more aggressive in its own way even even
the pauses are like you can't rest the
movie it feels like someone uh they'll
wait is on your chest for nearly three
hours it is a very emotionally draining
experience and I mean that in a very
positive way I don't think this is a
movie that is going to be in the
background of any party this isn't a
movie that's going to be washed casually
this is a film to be immersed in to be
experienced in this is
overwhelming uh so those are those are
my positives uh I I'm
trying to again this is probably the
movie I'm the most excited to give my my
spoiler discussion on because all the
things I want to talk about are they
were kept for me and I love that um the
things I didn't didn't love 100 were a
lot of the time it felt like they needed
to do a lot and they would leave a
moment that I was relishing in and and
there would be a bombardment of of Sight
and Sound in a way that felt like I
could have used like another 10 seconds
and I know that's uh that sounds like
splitting hairs but just a couple
moments felt like they needed to get to
a thing instead of letting me feel the
thing but like that's looking for a flaw
and then the main flaw had the the one
Central flaw
um was that to me the personification of
Namor was just different than how I
perceived the character the way I read
Namor is
um a certain type of snooty that I
didn't quite feel and and I want to dive
deep into that in a more spoiler
conversation but there were moments I
didn't feel quite like anymore and it's
it's no problems I have with the actor
it it's no problems I have with the way
he portrayed it but I feel like the
story
didn't allow for the way Neymar feels to
me now that said because the
personification they chose and because
of the storyline they chose it was able
to tell
arguably a more important story
um because of the story they chose and
the way Namor was
um delivered I do feel like we got more
of a look at Humanity again Humanity
through super Humanity if Namor was the
way I perceive him then a lot of the the
beats that really hit me wouldn't have
worked um so I think it was definitely a
juice worth the squeeze situation where
even my biggest flaw which is that I
didn't feel like every moment of Namor
felt like the common character the
reasoning behind it was very justified
in that some of my favorite moments were
because of these choices this is a very
hard thing to to not spoil but um I
really loved
how they navigated all of the you've
seen in the trailer's rivalry and I love
how they navigated the world in the UN
and the greater World At Large and I
will say to wrap this up that it is
probably my favorite
World building within the MCU that feels
like the world is growing in gravitas
versus it growing for the sake of
growing out the MCU it feels like the
world is growing not the universe is
growing it feels like the
culture is more deep it feels like the
other cultures are more Versed and and
have more of a tangibility to them as
opposed to just expanding out references
and expanding out things that we want to
see as fans this makes the world much
more tangible and so it's huge World
building but not in the traditional MCU
sense but in the traditional movie
making sense that's something I really
appreciate and enjoyed this movie
definitely uh wrecked me uh I was
definitely like I said emotional for
three hours and I really love the world
of builds the cultures it showed the
costume design as ever Ruth Carter just
crushed the acting as ever like Angela
Bassett here is such a Powerhouse she is
so so good in this uh Leticia Wright as
shuri I mean Winston Dukes Baku is a
scene stealer at all times just
Powerhouse is all around in the
production design the world's again the
world's built here like nothing else
that is going to do it for this
spoiler-free review that was very hard
to keep spoiler free the depths of the
world the acting the ability to balance
real themes the navigating of a very
very difficult thing and overall the way
it made you feel
is so unique to this film and the things
that juggled
um yeah I'm very excited to see this
again tomorrow but kind of forever
[Music]